hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to don't starve
together with Bob say hi Bob
hey everybody hi that's Bob over there
we were over here yeah yes he's over
there with his web clothes over there
yes he's over there me okay
so we're playing this again mostly
because we wanted to play it again
there's been a lot of updates but we
have not been able to not die as per the
last time we play this we died a lot
right Bob
yeah well and to be clear the name of
the game is tonestar we've successfully
accomplished that yeah starving is not
the problem I I was an idiot basically
well I mean what else is new right but I
mean I was especially an idiot because I
was wandering around the middle of the
night without my torch and then I just
fell over and died and you just super
died yeah exactly I don't even know
what's in the darkness that kills you
but a whole bunch of not goodness
happens and then I die I don't ah Santa
it's awesome so fun yeah so either way
we got a new server going up we got a
new field we're not cheating this time
so it's not a it's not a feel of just
every ruch resource here about loose
who's talking about cheating what's
cheating Oh No okay I was that was just
random happenstance yeah I forgot about
yeah I mean I was so great but so long
ago that I forgot so it was so
incredible or luck at that one juncture
definitely I've got all of those good
things to happen to us we just didn't
have the same luck this time around
right Bob
yeah no it's it was just one it was a
lucky round you know it was it was meant
to be that's why we that's why we did so
well uh-huh yeah wait didn't we dive
into or did we actually survive we might
have died I wouldn't I wouldn't put it
past Efes I was just saying that sounds
like what we would do it what you given
our past she cheat and then die anyway
every episode of this entire thing has
it's been us dying in more creative ways
than the last time so hopefully we won't
do that this time wait did we even come
up with a goal of what we wanted to do
this in uh survive to the end of this
first episode I don't know okay I'm
trying to get I'm trying to find some
gold I'm trying to try to do the things
and this stuff
yeah because mostly I just wanted to
play with Bob again because like we have
not we miss Bob when when Wade and Tyler
was over you like well I don't know why
I'm talking about you
if you're not here we miss you like we
must do a lot like I really wish you
were like you would've been great in the
spore series just because you would have
seen how bad Tyler was doing there ha ha
ha I wish I could have been there for
that that did look pretty hilarious you
watch it i watched the first few yeah oh
I don't know how many there actually
where I guess there were only like three
episodes right as I watched there's much
most of it there's two more that I have
to edit and upload but man it was so
unbelievable like I felt like I when I
was there I suddenly had an epiphany and
I understood what all the people
watching this series think when we're
playing this game I were okay every bad
I mean we're not dead yet we're not dead
yeah I still have crap for food but you
know it's a just start kinda sad
yeah anyway uh so my character is a
character that doesn't eat anything but
meat which is kind of detrimental
because there's no Beefalo here we have
there's if there's one thing we needed
it's for this to be more difficult so
good call good call now well I wanted to
be this character because she seemed
Scottish and I wanted to talk in the sky
you know how good my Scottish accent as
it is that is your good accent that's
like I specially it's the reason I'm
popular on YouTube it's that is that
really what what I mean I would think so
I mean okiya game if you could change
your feet he did mmm I love all that
sentence is somehow mostly h's if you
could yeah that's that's what Scottish
is such a people sound like yes Oh God
gorgeous like watch wait wait wait let's
enjoy what you just said out loud first
you just say to me Scottish is such a
beautiful language yes yes I did
uh I don't really need to make a joke
about that I just want to point it out
Scottish is a beautiful language you
know you know mark you're right you're
right I guess I guess Celtic the Celtic
language that's very yes yes thing it's
not it's not so much I don't know what
happened some Germans got in Scotland
things got weird
they wore kilts everything went wrong
I don't know I wasn't there some
horrible horrible thing happened and
that's how they decided to speak English
and all of our Scottish viewers just
left the sorry off to something else
sorry but it's okay they're all drunk oh
just like those'll Irish right haha as
far as I know the stereotype for
everyone in Europe is that they're just
drunk in America like you no matter who
it is if it's like French people English
people Scottish people the embed the
stereotype for Americans is ah they're
just drunks really I don't know is
everyone over there I mean I don't do
that way that's a banished people I
don't know the German searches for Irish
I mean even even the English like they
they they drink look like crazy man God
in like they mix it in their tea and
they have like well I'm speaking out of
my ass now I have no idea
doing anything I'm just following you
around because it's about to be
nighttime and I want to build a fire but
I don't want to build it in the middle
of nowhere
Oh God you have any rocks no dammit I
wasn't getting rocks I didn't find a
single nother Boulder I have one Flint
oh yeah I will make another fire here we
go well I had enough to make a fire but
you okay hey hey I'm the provider here
all kind the provider oh thank you I'm
the plumber can you feel the spit all
the way across Skype I can I remember
the sensation I you don't have to remind
me okay all right live streams of old
just spit people couldn't see the floor
but it was just an inch high off the
ground just nice spit yeah it marks mark
needs to get a new monitor like once
every month because he gets you crap all
over and you can't get it off because
you're not allowed to use cleaning
products on high-end monitors you know
you say that but right now because it
just turned night I guess he on the
stage my monitor oh I was that's mostly
on my ass but I am not at all even
remotely surprised by that fact is like
I I wish it wasn't the hot Sun tire what
the hot Sun it's night your characters
just a psycho my character is every
character besides Wilhelm or whatever
his name your character is like William
Frey
yeah william prynne I'm big fun I'm
Diggs had so yeah do you have actual
hell oh my gosh bill haha okay anyway
bad bad bad that day that sounded on for
me I bet that was not all I said are
really bad to me you're the one report
says it's really bad to everyone
watching too so we won't to worry about
that
so yeah we need to find some boulders or
some rocks or something oh basically
this field is so great let's abandon it
and go somewhere else
yep screw that alright we had enough
good luck with that
that's right there already Beefalo there
anyway yeah no you need in this game the
only thing I really wanted was beef
elope and why I picked this character so
that I could murder them and then yeah
yielder me you were trying to be a
Beefalo hunter yeah I mean we were poop
hunters before so let him sting you in
the heart is that how that works I was
though it was a Steve Irwin joke that
was it that wasn't just a Steve were
that was a Steve Irwin his dead joke
that was that joke simultaneously too
soon and to out Dana yeah I made it
happen
I found weird Wow hey hey you a fight
bro you went I found a way I found I
found weird people dude this is like B
land over here this is dangerous these
guys uh these guys ow well I got my
battle hello my god didn't what are you
doing to these pig people I they're not
pig people I don't kill them
I found fake people yeah butters pig
killed cutting the wrong people the the
weird the weird okay god they don't hurt
they don't hurt me at all oh I can just
wail on him
I killed one and I picked up a fish wow
that's cool okay I almost got when you
attack it plays action music it honks
honk if you could change your [ __ ]
oh god they do hurt me a little bit they
don't they don't really hurt me at all
like I got
very this battle helm that I have was
that frogs legs well yeah I got frog
legs and fish which I think both
counters meet so this is good for you
apparently good thing pvp's does it
don't get a man I'm trying all right
there we go gotta be hey let me give you
all this meat over here thanks oh you're
full of stuff hang on
I'll give you this and that oh thanks
buddy
you're welcome pal thanks friend
oh fish oh it does count fish works
sweet and physically good good you cook
those or something
well whatever I'll eat it raw you know
you know fish is probably really good
for you cuz it's got all those omega-3
fatty acids it exactly fish is great for
you and if you were to buy fish where
would you buy it at your local
supermarket I bet not I'd buy it at the
Ralph's on West Wester Tain's Westeros
the Westeros trout diamond throne the
primary delivery for fresh fish rats on
the Kings Road just north of King's
Landing cuz that doesn't mean [ __ ] to
you exactly
unless you're Game of Thrones fan where
you live in Westeros well who doesn't
who isn't a game of Thrones fan I just
mean just north of King's Landing might
as well be a thousand light years away
oh yeah exactly we travelled for three
months to get to the wall it's it's 12
miles away from King's Landing it's just
really slow travelling it's not oh
that's probably not true I'm sure
there's someone right now in the
comments who's like no no no I've worked
it out I worked out is that their voice
yeah yeah now are you I you don't know
yet you don't know I have a Minecraft
model of the entire of Westeros
including the lost dials or whatever
what was the other was the other
landmass call I forget the other one
it's across the Narrow Sea
it is um I forget I don't know who cares
I'm not that one guy curse that one guy
is like oh my god that one guy sounds
suspiciously like the one guy that
criticizes the game grubs that red is a
running joke Oh Aaron you don't know how
to play all a monkey with a wrench and
glasses could you better
you you are Iying doing right now oh no
I know who wasn't that guy who was it
was his jet or like Jeb yeah these game
grumps don't know how to play
they're the worst in this game oh god
that was the funnies see see the
difference between music gave me and the
gamers is they're actually funny so when
they son say something it's actually
hello I see people oppa watching Evo Oh
mark oh I found I found our campsite
brah I'm ruff
Brittish is our campsite didn't have
this poop I made it special oh I want
the poop did you poop it out for me I
did yes all that meat that I'm eating
you know is you heavy poop I've been
watching Bill Nye the Science Guy I know
exists it's on Netflix down rightist I'm
on like episode 25 I actually learned
that from your tweet and you went to go
watch it exactly I was like when I went
there who's like the number one most
popular watch that looks at the time
beating out their new series and whatnot
ah man or just the new what Bill Nye the
Science Guy orange it bill is the new
black hundreds don't lie the science guy
would say orange can't possibly be the
new black because that doesn't make any
sense that he yes that yes oh no I
interrupted my thing Oh giggity goo okay
I can make a fire pit now oh sweet is
this where our camp is gonna be then
where our camp is gonna be because it's
more all right
I'm glad a lot of thought and planning
went into that made fire aah
Wilson Wilson barbed wire doesn't know
where to put his campsite
he's a total scrublord you have no idea
Oh God those two people are talking to
each other I could just imagine a
comment battle between those two guys
actually honestly I don't know if I can
imagine head ah
all right everyone out in the comments
below try to imagine or be Jeb and
what's the name of the other guy uh Kyle
what would my name be it's gotta be
Jarek cause it sounds awesome to say in
that voice
oh man my friends call me wreck get it
hahaha racket videogames and my name's
Derek dear Rach oh is that now are you
going for a little bit Jarek get react
what are you doing dare I yeah well you
know that what's that from no you know I
don't either I just quoted a lot okay
from something I guess anyway well
whatever I'm gonna get this fish
let's get try keep going with Derek but
I don't even I don't even know what
Derek do you don't even know what Derek
do I don't even know what he do
Derek could be your character you a Gera
that makes my like tired chest hurt
hahaha clues you're back myself X I
clench up - oh you're right it resonates
in like turgid in 20 I was in your bowl
I've had it up to here with your
shenanigans Derek oh good you've gone
silent now I think I want to say I was
like oh oh don't laugh if you don't
belong oh man
do you don't even know the Anthropology
of the word genetic ins how dare you
that's it his catchphrase the gang up
how dare you oh god damn I want to point
I want to do a serious where I play like
counter-strike and Derek yes and all I
do is smack talk my own team the entire
jaw but you guys know my day just you
don't rush be you never rush be where
you in that spot you have a much better
angle from goose if you're kind of short
just broke my neck playing use over here
no thank you over even though I'm only a
silver Lee master or whatever my rank is
have you been playing go a lot yes I
love that game now exactly I love it
jontron played go a lot and he was
trying to get me into it and I picked it
up but I prefer to just play against
bots cuz you know how I feel
multiplayer online how you feel about
gold room as your by the time they found
the gold I've only been waiting about
10,000 years are you that would be over
there
based on their spawn and the shape with
a map so far I can't believe they didn't
anticipate this the trajectory of the
algorithm used to interpretate his nap
whose obvious they're so stupid
there is a fresh layer of spit all over
my mother I'm actually getting my uh my
pop filter a little bit spedde here I
don't you yeah dude you Derek's a
spitter man you don't even want to see
my pop filter it's it's good I did when
I first got it I could see through it I
don't have those hard plastic ones that
have like mesh underneath it's oh my god
I can't a completely opaque now I can't
there's like a subtle guffin blood bank
at least it's not like changing colors
uh it's a little got a little bit of a
shift gradient across would I have so
many rocks over here nice bro this is an
awesome awesome ridgeline uh uh that's
not something Derek would say it's
stupid sorry Derek yeah you betrayed
Derek how dare you how dare you
seriously though I got like 25 rocks
over here and I'm about to get like 20
more this is the [ __ ]
nice I'm getting moto is that a dog all
God oh hell I'll help god ham okay
bringing me I got a comment or two I'm
coming towards you a good dog okay dog
gets it alright there's my bad news beer
get your thing out got it huh oh-ho-ho
edge oh don't let me sorry
got him got him he dead dude nice Eddie
got some meat thank you thank you you
need that cuz you can only eat meat if
you forgot um its monster me obviously
monster meat is detrimental to your
health even if you cook it the trade-off
for hunger versus health is wholly worth
it for cook monster me how dare you are
using me eater
oh my god dude look at these gold Mane's
over here look at this [ __ ] oh oh it's
guarded by it dog though oh he's got
boned
oh nice god I killed him til quick your
boss I am I'm good just all this gold
and you just do all the murdering
tumbleweed
how dare you in Azaria yeah oh [ __ ]
how'd you hear you oh god knows that
voice crack was on purpose it's going I
goes you weary how dare you bring that
up to me again I judge stuff God laid
Eric to rhetoric microphone I didn't
mean to get crap all over you I'm sorry
waveform I didn't mean to peek you
everywhere but I set my [ __ ] up before
we started recording I was like alright
that's perfect I guarantee you every
Derek quote absolutely just gonna peak
harder than Derek at 11:30 p.m.
hurt seriously yeah people don't know
this is all scripted every single
episode I've ever Derek is a carefully
shaped characters exactly we
intentionally made Derek to be as
appealing to the kids as possible oh my
god you're murdering old you need okay I
hope my hellhounds about to break away
really relate out of here um hopefully
just little bit longer huh
were there any Pigman anywhere no well I
mean besides those we killed I mean
there were the Holmes guess we just need
to keep retreating yeah just go back to
the camp I guess cuz night anyway uh I
stopped to get gold and I was stupid I
got greedy you need me to come back here
uh this guy's like on my ass but you
still have one on you I do not I'm gonna
come towards you I got one with me okay
I can kill one yeah that was just like a
hull fuckload oh he's gone okay
oh cool so weird so our camp is in this
field right here it's like an oh here it
is Oh see you got my strategic plan
buried fire
thank you do you have rocks I need rocks
yeah I'm gonna make that you a battle
helm and apparently a battle helm is
like super I don't lie pick up only some
rocks
a dude oh there we go I'll give you 20
of my 40 rocks cool so I'm gonna guess a
science Makena no I'm gonna make you a
battle helm here take this
holy [ __ ] very very good this battle
helm is 1% so don't pick up that one
it's I made a science Mecca Hina you
made a science machine it's Irish wow
that hurt my throat it's on Oh Derek
like a scientist akin to how Derek's a
psychopath yeah he's not even like a
school nerd yeah in school he's 46 he's
47 for all man we were on the same
wavelength there were you saying 47 I
said 46 apparently 550 is a creepy age
range we just knows Derek
oh well Derek's in the comments right
now how dare you ah [ __ ] [ __ ] because
I'm 47 does not mean that I'm not
incredible to my field so so okay
Derek's done and Derek's done oh I can
make endothermic fire what in the balls
does that even mean cold fire this fire
is from opposite day yeah cold fire this
for oh I was like whoa what happened to
the English in that sentence no this
fire is from opposite day it's like you
said it like cyanide and Happiness and
this fire is from opposite day like the
firemen opposite day opposite day as a
poor and fire on the house Oh busy day
all right I'm in a prototype a shovel
and a shovel what else is important man
I got all kinds of resources over here
uh I don't know I don't know we don't
play this game to press we play it I'm
eating seeds that's probably not pro
strats right there
oh well we're not to the farming stage
it meant to eat berries but whatever
whatever I'll just eat these seeds you
okay do you need more food um I'm gonna
kill it tomorrow I'm gonna kill Beefalo
yeah tomorrow we hunt tomorrow we hunt
the hunt is on gentlemen
oh man you must defend your honor
all you say my iron how dare are you
question my honor I just want the
comments to be nothing but how dare you
I'll share you how near you
God oh my prototype in a backpack yeah
brah Oh back the backpack makes you
tired or so you uh you need waffle we
can set them and they won't despawn
right exactly yes so set them here and
as soon as days bricks I'm going on
cones be fooled we'll be floored Dib I
will I will craft another well we all
make you oh [ __ ] I don't have gold do
you have any more gold uh yeah I've got
five gold and he's two gold I'll get you
a battle spirit too cuz a battle spear
very strong hey I got your on here you
go
okay I give you that I have a beard look
at me look at you Oh your pockets are
full um right
I'll drop it on the ground okay okay a
beautiful time for you I'm going to put
the backpack on I'm gonna put all of our
rocks and wit not in backpacks mm-hmm
okay oh well like where where do they
valhallen come from is that Norwegian or
is that like it well the Nordic region
countries um oh she is ringing I am
filling up with water
what does that mean what the hell is
that symbol mean oh it just means you're
wet oh okay
I'm one wet well I'm here what what okay
re they hurt they hurt they're okay they
hurt they hurt a lot do you need me to
come help uh maybe
well I'm gonna try to lure one away okay
I like the one here back off okay all
right I'm coming to you hey okay it
wasn't that bad they don't hurt that bad
but they took a lot of health Wow
they take a lot of it one down or you
could just you could help it I've got
another ax cos my axe is on 2% well it
gave you a spear like oh you gave me a
spear that's right it's on the ground
over there isn't it
fanox I meant to pick that up I'm glad
it went to such good use
thanks mark you're welcome I'll pick up
all your meat well you got I got it
thank our let's go hon buddy thank you
thanks for all your help mark thank
you're welcome but I'm not the one who
has to do everything around here
oh man I'll bring back the Scottish
accent don't don't don't don't question
me guy oh we murdered that Beefalo man
it would be murder murdered him man I'll
pick up the meat you can pick up the
other things
unless you don't hope it's no I got lots
of space I'm every I'm an empty person
on the inside it's empty
oh don't uh how dare you how dare you
question my empty I'll have you know yes
yes is by toys I need to have I need I
needed something about Star Trek
do you think I can change my fate how
dare you ouch ouch Beefalo while you do
this do you take a lot of damage
mmm I'm at like three-quarters health
I'm okay
did one hit 3/4 health really I'm a
worse man
okay leave the leave the fighting dear
to me leave the fighting to me leave the
fighting to me in no wait well that's
not Scottish well have asked I was held
in I just I was like Arnold action movie
aren't leave the light to me you do it
like did you know all that sequence make
so much more money than movies
I'm not yellow you're mean I love
California and that was - I was too
coated above California well I don't I
don't know a bother you going for Arnold
on that second try we're at vows for the
resonator oh the government all
California come to our state no skiing
now mix Derek with that voice how the
[ __ ] huh I'm jyler one of these guys
away
oh my god you got the whole II know I
know I know I know
but they're gonna talk I got a plan see
see I see give up okay and then just
want alright yeah get always I want to
have a go
I'm gonna open a sample one of your best
how dare use I'm just going to wear for
all Buffalo just repeat how give you I
dare you how dare you how dare you ok
this one good oh I'll take two I didn't
it we can take it oh gosh okay I'm okay
I'm okay
let's you're doing it alright dead yep
we're good and you're oh look it's just
it's just a baby I guess okay alright
I'll kill you
try group okay or okay alright nevermind
alright it's fine run no I got it I
don't take a lot of damage
let's grab what you can yeah oh yeah you
wanna kill I'll kill I buff a wobble die
be buh buh buh buh
they can't hit you if we dude
oh oh we goal was not to die that
markiplier doesn't know how didn't he
watch his helm strength what a noob
everyone knows you have to watch
durability during fights I know Derek
what a scrublord
I can't believe it Derek you are an okay
guy in my book say your silence says it
all no need to put them options in this
god I guess that's the end of my absence
such an unbelievable nuba store you've
got damn ignorant douche bag thanks
Derek your comments mean the world to me
good work markiplier markiplier cuz you
are you are you know how good you are
ARCA try harder you goddamn oh there's
been a fun episode anyway thanks for
joining me Bob and thanks for joining
Derek uh I'm sure I stopped welcome
you're not welcome how dare you speak to
me alright hey wait god oh god damn
alright so thank you everybody so much
for watching check out Bob's channel for
more stuff that we've done we
might play more don't starve but hey I
died like an idiot so knows what's gonna
happen thanks again everybody and as
always we will see you in the next video
but I am such an idiot I can take him
look at me
I'm so great oh is it good ending to an
episode
I guess ah Derek you said ice like idiot
Derek it's so genius
I love Derek oh man I'm like that's my
first actual character I really hope
Derek gets animated I really hope I
wasn't laughing too much over your lines
I just wish I could have stopped myself
from laughing kept doing them I start
laughing I can't get my throat clench
down hard enough to make that say it
really does like your whole chest has to
be involved Gary oh that was good though
oh that was fun no I think I think
people really like that